I love starting with a curveball at the
beginning so the curveball for you guys
uh you've done both of you have done
some really cool stuff uh besides this
movie which we're going to get into if
someone has never seen anything you've
done what is the first thing you'd like
them watching and why the first thing
you'd like them watching and why oh God
that's good Steve you did it you really
did it and why swing wow that's not
having a curveball that's like a that's
like crazy that's all right you pitched
a perfect game on that I would just
blast into another dimension
right um because um I guess what would I
have them start with you know what maybe
my show you know yeah that's that that's
that seems about right right I think
yeah no that makes sense that makes
sense I think I think it would be um
what would they start with they should I
mean I may I I the obvious answer is
that you should just watch just watch
Substitute Teacher and then go go from
there and do whatever you want go down I
mean what whatever rabbit hole that
takes you down that's I think where
people should start it's kind of like
the primer for me okay what is for both
of you what is the most nervous you were
the night before the first day of
filming you're like oh my God I'm about
to do this and F
mhm oh wow maybe maybe the Predator
maybe it was the Predator because we we
had done so much training I just wanted
I just wanted to look I wanted so badly
to look like a Soldier I was like please
let me just look a little bit like
something like a soldier something yeah
I think that that I think I was really
nervous before that that and and uh no
not that jingle jangle it was jingle
jangle it was the dancing it was the
dancing and jingle jingle that's what it
was for me mhm that sounds n wracking I
would say everyone in the beginning
every every single time um yeah like you
always hit that that like level of like
oh my God you know am I gonna be able to
pull this off pull it off yeah so uh
jumping into this project um when did
you both decide that you wanted to be
the voice and like every upcoming
animated
project oh man oh my God it's almost
like it wasn't our choice just like it
just started it just started happening
and I'm just like just started happening
and and also the other thing that's that
we we've remarked upon that's been
really interesting is we played Birds
we've played birds all the time
times you played you've played five
birds and I have played Four Birds it
took me a while I had to count them down
and then I counted them down I've played
Four birds and it's not like the best
way to open up for me personally my
Tinder profile you know what I mean
right it's not like it's not like the
best opener you know you know I we at
Buffalo Wild Wings of all places you
know um so I really enjoyed this movie
and I think uh Mike White's script mixed
with Benjamin's Direction it's a really
good movie what are you both really
excited for audiences to see I'm being
really sincere about this um I'm really
excited and I'm being serious about this
I'm really excited for people to see
simply see it what what the production
design like the the how beautiful the
movie is and some of the camera work is
something I don't think I've seen a lot
in animation them like especially in the
city scenes when they're in the cities
and how the camera Zips around and goes
around buildings and leaves the birds
and comes back to the birds it's the
camera works really great it's it's it's
Absol Sumptuous to see I think it's
going to people are going to be really
surprised at how beautiful it is yeah I
I think Benjamin did an amazing it's
very visually stunning and I think that
uh you know it's it's heartwarming it's
funny and and it's um it should be seen
in theaters yeah yeah I completely agree
um one one of the things this is going
to sound I hope I word this right what I
really liked I think is that there were
just no dumb jokes there's like no like
fart jokes no stupid jokes it's like all
earned the humor yeah through story yeah
yeah I think I think that that's a
really good way of putting it yeah and
then there is physical humor there's
kind of fun fall down humor but it's all
cause and effect I think it all happens
for a reason and the right and the right
characters are doing it at the right
time yeah and there there's a genuine
story there I think it's very like
obviously relatable which is a lot of
like uh what what what these do yeah you
both uh you both have done a lot of
VoiceOver what is it like how do you
sort of get ready the night before the
morning you're going into the booth um
because you've done it so much you know
like is there like a mental thing or you
just like you know what you're getting
at this point now like how does it work
the one thing that you just make sure
you don't blow out your voice the the
night before that that's the worst thing
that can happen that's that's if you can
come come to set or to set to the to the
um to wherever where you're recording
with your voice then it's all it's all
workable that's really good yeah you
have to have your voice you your voice
that's the only thing that yeah and you
can you can and and it it does help it
does help to be rested like I try to be
rested before a voiceover session
because it takes because if you're tired
it takes something out of you it's like
you can't get to where you need to get
to vocally sometimes like you say a word
in it over and over again like you know
you don't want to get into that that
zone where it's like it's G be nothing
makes sense anymore yeah uh I have an
individual question for each of you um I
can't believe you're going to be voicing
bumblebee yes in Transformers one I've
heard that Chris and Scarlet have said
to me that the footage looks really cool
oh cool I'm curious what it's like
voicing a Bumblebee and I watched the
trailer it's not out yet for Kung Fu pan
to 4 this morning and notice that you're
again a voice in an upcoming uh am I
wrong about this cuz I'm like oh no no
you're oh yeah know you look I'm like oh
maybe I'm wrong about this but yeah I
saw you have another big you know
animated thing what can you tease about
your role in that it just that it was
incredibly fun to to work obviously
again with with Jack who I think is is
incredible uh an incredible perform
former um that's so good oh thank you
yeah thank you yeah that's great I
didn't know that you were doing that
that's awesome yeah really awesome um
like I said it's almost like you guys
are dominating every upcoming animated
project animated project we're we're
thinking of our own we're trying to work
on what are we what are we going to do
on our own thing yeah we're on our own
little didly where it's a prequel to
migration so chump chump and dely
specifically chump and Elroy yeah yeah
we think we we might do that and then
we'll do other voices in that movie we
in that movie in the
only in the entire movie and we um oh
Transformers yeah the the the trans um
playing bumblebee I it's funny not a lot
of affectation to my voice the director
of of this wanted really just wanted he
goes I really want your voice I just
want Keegan's voice so it's kind of
Keegan as Bumblebee and you you you'll
see it's interesting it's not it's
unlike this where I'm working in a
dialect or I'm doing something with like
Super Mario Brothers where I'm really
trying to disguise my voice voice this
one's I'm I'm bringing a lot of me to it
on that note I need to stop I'm just
going to say I really enjoyed this and I
know it's going to be a huge hit thank
great thanks D
thanks